in the interest of being thorough let's
start at the beginning with the origins
of werewolves the supernatural
transformation of a person into a wolf
is referred to as lycanthropy and the
first time that lycanthropy appears in
any historic text is in the story of
Gilgamesh that I mentioned earlier
Gilgamesh is a Sumerian warrior king who
rejects the advances of the Goddess
Ishtar afraid that she would transform
him into a wolf as she had to her
previous admirer talk about a toxic axe
this is the first mention of a man
turned into a werewolf or dog likee
creature the lycanthropy is more of a
side note to the actual story and
notably it's used as sort of a
punishment or threat the term ly
anthropy originates from Lon a legendary
King from Greek mythology Lon had the
Greek God Zeus over to his place as a
guest you know just hanging out with the
boys and Len wanted to impress Zeus by
offering him a human sacrifice carving
up one of his own Sons but Zeus did not
appreciate this he wasn't really into
the whole filicide thing so he decided
he was going to punish Lon by
transforming him into a wolf